I know there's a republican celebration
but I have the honor of introducing a
man who is so Democratic he picks on
everybody equally even a little kid like
me
Mr Don Rickles
[Music]
be funny
[Applause]
first black kid I ever saw it'll
definitely never play basketball
oh yeah your people that's what I love
about this city there's a chemistry I
swear to god you're an eye are you an
Irishman you an Irish kid
what are you a bird
good evening Mr President nice to see
you sir and your lovely wife Nancy it's
it's a big treat for me to fly all the
way for California to be here for this
kind of money
I don't care what you are you're fat
and I love the black people we need you
people I swear because no Jew is going
to make up a train foreign
I come out I come out and it's my
trademark I tend to maybe jump around a
little bit what do you really think
about it I think you're making a fool
yourself
I thank Neil Armstrong or Neil over here
Neil you're down
gee so now I'm gonna get sick
I don't Mighty get it get yourself an
injection or something but my uncle I
don't need this I was a healthy Joy come
out here I can see when it shows are I'm
gonna be in a hospital going it was Jay
Leto
when we go on hunts we run out of
animals we chase her
I tell you I was frightened to death but
it was a great experience you have two
kids two fine Sons three
was that in the trailer Camp
um and I have two and I have one in the
Philippines
like a dummy I stopped but uh
my lovely wife is sitting there knowing
that when I die she's going to come into
a lot of money Bob Hope as you all know
he's in the back standing there with
three soldiers in American flag saying
find another wall
foreign
peace
and I've been kindness and warm
I love the black people
the black people in my life
my world
they do what they're told
we're honoring Mr T
why
I met this man many many years ago on
the 7-Eleven store and he said give me
your money
[Applause]
that's right Chinese
fix
the Chinese person they're going who's
Chinese who's Chinese Plant I say with
due respect
28 years ago we did Kelly's Heroes and I
haven't heard from you since
[Applause]
plant
I say it nobody else has said it and I
say it from my heart you're a lousy
actor
Spielberg and all these guys at the
table we know Clint I know you
Clint's idea of a good time is sitting
on a pickup truck watching his dog bark
mother Eastwood is laughing
Knowing damn well you never had so much
money in your whole life
the sun played the bass we sat through
that
now probably your daughter will come up
here and do the tangle
but you know Clint and I know that I
have so much on you which I won't say
tonight
because if I spill it out you're going
to be back in rawhide
but Clint I understand you're engaged
now I don't know if that's official but
whatever the story is dear good luck
a lot of Happiness dear oh
[Applause]
my God
but we had great days together Clint
let's have lunch
God bless you and I love you
sugar Ray is a great Champion sugar we'd
ask you to talk but you know the blacks
your lips lock
how long have you had that
anyway uh
you don't have enough trouble now you
gotta twitch
thank you
man sitting there like a Jew whale and
he's twitching
people like Bob hope he's not Irish he's
not Jewish he's not Italian he's not
black just All-American guy when he was
born he he came out of his mother with a
flag wrapped around him
and Angeline you're a lovely woman and
gorgeous and I'm happily married but my
wife is ill
it tingles my wife's body just lays in
the bed
I got an old walrus but I gotta be nice
because everything's in her name
kid the black man and you know that baby
and you were beautiful to Telly Telly is
a great Greek and you're a great black
man and I'm a Jew and I say this for my
heart on behalf of the Greeks and the
Jewish people don't move into the
neighborhood
I I would be I would be amiss if I
didn't mention that Bob Hope is here
tonight it's good to see you Bob he's
here because there's no war on
Milton my item still Hair Milk wonderful
guy 65 years in the business huh 65
years in show business and you don't
want to walk away
it's all over Milton grab a cab
Secretary of State's here
and Billy Graham nice
Anyway by the way for the first time
tonight I met your son oh you did yes
he's a wonderful kid oh good yeah he
gave me uh some cocaine and some oh he
did
yeah
my kids Sammy you're a black man I took
a guess
if you ain't black you fell into a
bucket of M M's
got it right in all right you good Conan
do good I don't boy Andy patty cake
[Applause]
um
[Laughter]
Freddy Prince is your buddy and we need
the Puerto Rican people I quote the
grades of the the grades the words of a
great Puerto Rican Manuel hapezius who
said to me in New York llama coffee
where did you go did you take her
somewhere did you travel I know you
could be a taker it's not a dog I gotta
walk into my wife
that I take it someplace yeah here here
Barbara here roll overhead
we were working at the Grand Casino in
outside of Memphis outside how far
outside what the hell are you from the
travel agency I don't remember casino
gambling remember nobody what are you
what are you my guardian I'd like to
tell you where I go
40 million Jews I got to meet a truant
officer here
the fact was the security guard and by
the stage door in those days you went
right out into the casino when you came
off with the show this isn't too fast
for you no no okay
thank you
you're looking at you're looking at me
like I'm a chemistry set
and he used to stand by the door you
know every night every night and I'd
come out and go stand back everybody
stand back Mr Rickles is coming girl
stand back stand back there was nobody
there
my wife said to me last night as we laid
in bed she said as little thing young
and I said baby young is not the point
it's what's in Your Heart Right Lucy
Lucy put her in a home
look at this the husband went yeah
I'm delighted that you have a show
because you're fresh you're funny you're
great and I want you to know something
from my heart I never liked you
[Applause]
but go sell I will mention your name
only because you have asked for it
Frank Sinatra would be here tonight but
there was too much excitement so he
called it off uh she's I'm sure she's
very active in her social life I don't
mean I don't mean the bed and things
like that you don't mean an acrobat no
no no
not a high wire
like that you know
and I know you're very very you deep
constantly do you anyway
dad put it let's get it
why do we laughed away because we must
that's right
yeah
oh that's very sweet comedian everybody
loves you up here thank you Don let's
have lunch oh gee by all means come on
up and see me give me a break lady yeah
God bless you we'll work it out
for me all right so welcome to New York
did you have are you having fun here oh
yeah I got in the car and I was hijacked
last night yeah of course you were of
course I went out last night no I worked
the lobby I was in the hotel folding
newspapers for tomorrow remember the
words of a great negro I say that
honestly all peoples are alike we are
all working you live in my neighborhood
I live in yours right Sam right are you
crazy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I would address somebody get a phone
book so you can see me
[Applause]
Marty
when we see all the films you did none
of them were great
Darren McGavin you're the night stork is
my favorite show in fact I used that one
your show as a nightlife when I flew
with the wife
foreign
being snooped Eagle double G but uh
somehow some weight keep coming up with
funky ass [ __ ] like every single day you
hear that done no I'm deaf
I like you very much Tyler
I like you more than I thought I would
like you
please sit down because we could be
married in an hour
[Applause]
I'd like you to know this is Nell Carter
like this I did I had the pleasure of
being a guest star on her show give me a
break I brought her a lovely gift and
she said I'm not talking to you man I'm
not talking to you she's a lovely lovely
star you ask her
I've seen her in a bathrobe in the
dressing room and people go I'm being
sucked under
how far it keeps calling me on the phone
saying why is that black guy getting the
bigger lines
George isn't jealous but when you go to
bed tonight try to listen for a clock
is getting smaller and smaller tell him
what you told me how you fed up with the
blacks and you don't want them in your
neighborhood
[Applause]
but we need the blacks without them to
be no Olympics
the Chinese right Chinese this girl here
if you're not get your eyes fixed
I'm [ __ ] a Chinese box and they're
going who's Chinese who's Chinese you're
in the Air corps yes I am ours
would you rise
put a rubber band on your can and you
can take off
she's a big son of a gun oh my God you
ever think of putting a window on your
face and becoming a building
what's your first name my darling
Jewel and how long you've been married
two years it's 300 pounds don't you get
worried when he makes his move
there's what you're doing now
my idol since I'm a kid but now Milton I
say this for my heart
show business and your life by self be
thee with your new book love thee and
know thyself Milton he's old he
understands
we went uh oh many years ago my wife and
I when Trump Plaza just went up and we
said we're going to see the apartments
this is your wife Barbara I'm talking to
that
no it's a hooker from Detroit
[Applause]
you're going to Brooklyn like it's
exciting
build a bridge on your ass and go home
early
Jack Penny is over on the end he didn't
want to go for the table
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I swear shut up I hate when I when I
Spade butts in now
I look around this room and it's just
the home of the blacks
and they say three
anyway
God bless you black people I love you I
really do
as you're laughing here I'm sure one of
you guys is up in my hotel room robbing
me
people Phyllis Diller you're a dear
friend and I must tell you God bless you
God has given you the way you look
ashamed of it when you were born you
probably hit the wall
Dodgers in the older tummy would say oh
the best one he said go out to the mound
and take the picture out on appreciation
is true and I and I put on the uniform I
said jump the tummy you'll get fine
don't worry just go out there I walk out
to the moon in the game huh in the
middle of the game no in Detroit
how did you get this show I don't know
tomorrow
telling a story what do you think it was
yeah just put out sister oh to God you
got the job I can I can go back if you
want no I love you try go out to the
mountain big Mexican kids out there and
I said give me the ball you can't take
that out of the game where are you
I said the the manager I'm taking the
ball you can't take the ball back right
out loud give me back and I grabbed the
ball with that Harry window set who's
got arrested so it was a great umpire he
runs out rips off the mask and he says
it's Don Rickles can you get me two
tickets to the Dean Martin Show
look at this wonderful day Frank caution
his whole life is Bert Lancaster Joey
Bishop who passed away and wasn't told
about it foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in restaurants and when I first met
right when I first yes they always ask
me what do you think of this girl you
think it's okay you know and I gotta
check these girls out you know right
yeah you know I'm married 51 years to a
hooker
oh that's a joke she's backstage now
going I don't think that's funny
from Youngstown Ohio right what's that
town you come from Steubenville why
that's better anyway uh
Ohio
[Music]
dinero is sitting there God bless you
Bob he's got the beard on to know him as
a treat he's one of the great actors of
our time you ask him uh
you asked him they'll tell you you have
to put the blacks the whites the purpose
mostly the blacks
remember the word George Foreman who
said after the Muhammad Ali fight was
that down
three of us in the dressing room Dean
Martin Frank Sinatra and me you know I
was sitting there and I'm trying we're
ready to go on for the president you
know so Frank says no drinking guys now
you understand no drink you know you got
it we're not going to take anything and
regularly you know we're not gonna take
no drinks no drinks I'm not gonna have
anything and Franco's out of the room
and Dean opens up his coat and there's a
row of booze right in the corner
and that night we made Ronald Reagan
know he's alive
to the black
Friday night if the white man and the
Negro can work in harmony the people
know get your wife folk and the man is
harmony with love
oh God
[Laughter]
we're gonna have a baby real dummy Jack
take a good look at your face you
it needs surgery he must have ran into a
cab on an angle
yes what's the occasion what's the
occasion tell me the occasion who are we
honoring
what
forget him who else
it's nerd I gotta come out here I gotta
try to do a job now 28 hours of
entertainers and hi Bob how are you I
spoke to the home you're going to sit up
Friday anyway I'll tell you this look at
the astronauts sitting over here jeans
turned and went to the moon hasn't been
straight since
big names here tonight
and with the greats turned out for you
Kay Medford who had a very busy schedule
in downtown Hollywood looking for bad
apples
good luck to you I spoke to the people
in Bethlehem they expect you
nice to see you Jeff what do you do for
a living Jeff nothing nothing
nice to see it what do you do for a
living Mr Collis I'm an optometrist oh
wonderful I hope it goes away
maybe that would be all right for you in
Optometry
but I've been sitting around on the
beach all day waiting for birds to die
in the early days you you tried acting
first at the Active studio right right
here in New York well it wasn't active
Studio it was too big for that yeah uh
I was at the American Academy of
dramatic arts which I graduated from and
I'm very proud of that and I really am
and the audience is too
and you became friends
sounds like a Bob Newhart turnout
you're a lovely woman Lawanda good luck
in your plans to go White
Connie Stevens van Marga takes a cab
you'll be hot in this business
made the claim that he was my closest
friend I have never met Bob nobody
Bob Newhart goes to many gay parties
foreign
next to me at the beach you know that
thanks for all the visits anyway
I'm living about two blocks from the
abroad never shows up come by and say
hello
closer than two blocks I have no lines
Julia just not anyway
[Music]
this man was married to a great many
women in his life they're all flat now
but it's a great night Bob I'm so happy
for you really but do us a favor
get off the air
I mean how long I mean he had the
soldiers to the Navy they're getting
tired every time there's a war you're
right there in Iran they're fed up
they're fighting you go I want to tell
you with your golf club it's over I'm a
friend don't annoy people go go to La
Costa sit in the steam room don't bother
people
tonight I'm fed up I swear
[Music]
George at least has oh bones
this shot has a song to get off you have
nothing
would you would you stand up there
[Applause]
can I grab you a bottle legs I want a
dust
[Applause]
there you go
ah it's lovely to see you over here
buddy over here
you staring at them for no that was so
sweet to stand up I guess the underwear
stuck laughs
that's so sweet of you really when you
get older you know you get that kind of
reception you you want to walk away and
say why am I with him yeah
Filipinos
are you Filipinos oh God two and a half
years two and a half years looking for
your uncle
World War two big one big one
Cebu taclobin then guy and go Mindanao I
was there all all I'll be with you in a
minute
all trees all jungle now big cities
wonderful we went up to Manila and
MacArthur's still sitting there going am
I dead
God bless you great country I'm not
going back there is
what does that mean that means get off
my mind
that's all the way in the back
[Applause]
hey Obama wins this is your state
yeah
seven eighties working in a lounge in a
Sahara and of course he's hilarious and
everybody that was anybody in town that
meant anything come to watch him people
guys would cut their show so they can
get out in time to watch them I mean he
was the biggest drawer and customers
couldn't get in
they everybody wanted to see Rickles and
one night he gets a guy at the bar they
sang to him
come here Nazi bite the stick Kiss the
Ring Nazi come here Nazi hey Nazi Nazi
I'll show you this nothing stand up
and a guy stands Rickles on a stage the
stage is seven feet tall
the guy stands up and if he stands up
he's not on a stage he's eye to eye
a record system
you want to spit on a Jew
[Applause]
[Music]
who told you to butt in I'm getting fed
up with you that's Dave Wilson our
director I'm fed up with you Dave I
never liked you the cast doesn't like
you and we're fed up Dave and I hope you
go home to the wife tonight try to make
love and miss
[Applause]
that was the other guy
[Applause]
God bless there's a new thing called
dress up thank you
I mean we worry about the homeless but
you're a Jew derelict
I've always liked you better than the
other guy thank you
[Applause]
anyway uh
God bless you black or white we're
working for a same cause to find you
work anyway I've been doing so great
looking God bless you trust is a Jew and
Safari anyway uh I've never met a name
anyway
um
[Applause]
Hallelujah
get the black chick to back it up
I make jokes about the black people and
why not because I'm that one
good seeing you Don do you like the
California life
of course my hunting dogs we have a
bigger State the wife keeps running on
the grounds saying we're rich we're rich
it's It's a Wonderful Life it was better
than Miami in two rooms with my mother
rest her soul lifting up the curtain and
saying do you have a girl in there
no it's a great life you ought to come
out here Larry as soon as you can chip
in and get a jacket
you know I don't know where I'm looking
I'm talking to a blank screen you're
over there I don't know where I'm
talking to I feel like I'm Ray Charles
without my organ
what do you think of our studios in Los
Angeles I think they're cheap and they
should be painted bad area really well I
walked into the offices one big drape
and 100 people sitting at a desk going
they're all days people with days
Larry do yourself a favor walk away from
this you don't need it nobody gets CNN
in California a little German guy in the
cellar is still trying to read Hitler
he's going I think I got Larry King it's
a little little seller Don you're
getting am I right are you getting gray
yes Larry I'm getting older doing shows
like this
what
do we know each other well at least 18
19 years something I'm fed up
he started me in the old days in New
York Basin Street East we'll go back
that far that's right you hung around
New York and ran every Club in town
Buddy Rich is your idol I understand
well we've made a few rounds yeah you
Buddy Rich in all those days Ed you
weren't there then you you're in Jersey
with your wife saying you want more
Taffy
and uh
how's Victoria she's got a lovely wife
yeah
11 years old I found it yesterday in the
park going with my Eddie where is
a nice conservative Jewish lovely girl
lovely bar some more for all whatever
she don't like to bring up the age but
it's starting to show the neck it's
starting to hang a little bit but I'll
tell you this look at those people in
the balcony you could have been sitting
at Bob's table but you didn't want to
chip in
foreign
ero
it's not a holiday sit down good evening
Don
how are you buddy Frank this is one of
the most exciting nights I'm in a tux
heads and a tux George Burns God bless
you the senior man and this man did not
figure you were big enough to dress up
I personally am fed up that I'm dressed
like this of course the last time I was
it was in Brooklyn when Carmine
gambonanzo said Guido's gone
now Italians please don't phone in I am
a Jew and you're Italian so we're all
working for one cause to find out how
this girl got to look like that
before I feel great before you before
you jump all over me for me
all right
I want to tell you that I'm so happy
about the success of your show I really
am thanks you're deserving thanks good
show funny stuff that's a funny joke
nice coming from you Frank I appreciate
it and I've gotten a lot of shots ready
to cover the decubita
and uh Carson they've all made shots at
me and uh with fun and with love and I'm
delighted because I think we have a
great group of kids I love the kids on
the show they're all Clements a dick
Slattery we've added as a fine Captain
and the ratings came in this week and it
seems America is finding us and we're
delighted I'm glad for you I think it's
Saturday it's about time actually it's
about time
uh what else is new Frank well I'll tell
you what's new the following people when
the report to an alley in Brooklyn
[Music]
see with Frank if I may say Frank
because you've been singing and dancing
and just breaking it up out here uh
with Frank they always make it like
gangsters Italians or gangsters Jews
have all the money well that's a fact
[Applause]
like Italian guys in the right the Irish
Raider always the politicians Carol
George George up
Florida going don't make
sure I'll give you 500. you don't even
have to stay with it
[Music]
I'll take 300.
I love him and I I know so many years
and he's a great man and Ed I never
liked you
Ed was in the Marine Corps when the
planes were attacking Pearl Harbor he
was going
hurry back
hurry back John
when I ask you a very honest question I
want an honest answer
who is your favorite
male singer honest yeah dick Haynes
never I've heard you with the modern
years of the Paramount oh you always
annoyed I'll watch The Ink Spots The
Mills Brothers notice how I picked black
guys because they
black people
I must tell you Frank it's all over for
you Frank you're you always say to me
and always he says with warmth and love
he says to be done stop at the age age
is how you feel and I can hear my mom
and my darling wife who's not even in
the audience your wife Barbara's in the
audience I spotted her because she's
loaded like this the jewelry laughs
[Applause]